[Música]
para toda a gente é ver a conceitos
diferentes a justiça não é a mesma coisa
para todos nós e eu queria começar um
pouco e há várias idéias beluxa para
quem observa e consigo mista
às vezes falamos da justiça só o nome
que nós falamos mal para nós a justiça
somam consiste em cortar ou maio
dividida em dois lados
o sol não tentou quando sugeriu que uma
criança fosse cortado ou maio
descobrir quem é a verdadeira mãe se
alguém dissesse isso é bom então eu
posso ficar com parte das pernas
o som mondry esta não é mãe seguramente
não querem crianças em cortado ao meio e
descobriu quem era a mãe através de um
ardil que não tinha a ver com intenção
pro da área escutar a criança em duas
rodadas
mas a justiça tem para nós várias
representações cênicas estéticas por
exemplo na antiga grécia é deusa hoje
deusas indivíduos que seja
verdadeiramente é deusa grega da justiça
há uma pequena disputa entre uma das
mulheres e uma outra senhora
uma outra deusa uma terceira deusa mas o
que acontece é que regresse à justiça
não tinha os olhos vendados justiça
queria ver bem
metem a sua espada com a qual se impõe
por tem poder impor à força quando os
destinatários da justiça são
representativos e não querem cumprir os
seus ditames
já a justiça começava a deusa da justiça
de romã era mesmo justiça vem dos para
ser mais justa ao reatamento essa sua
intenção não podemos conferir
mas a história diz-nos que assim
vendroux mantendo a espada e também
avança a balança para pesar os vários em
3 e para simbolizar o equilíbrio e
cuidada
esta é nossa idéia de justiça uma ideia
que depois nós confundimos um pouco com
a ideia do direito idas do ice mas não
são seguramente a mesma coisa
por exemplo os países onde existem
regimes ditatoriais também têm leis as
ditaduras tenham lá isso já em tribunais
que fazem com
- nós tem sanções para quem não cumpri
los
e portanto nós não podemos confundir o
direito hoje joabio o que é obrigatório
com o que é justo mas não entendo um
pouco de dúvida então afinal o que que
justo se não é o que está nas lojas
eu tenho que contava então é muito cedo
para contar notas mas esta é sobre
advogados contavam uma história que
distingue claramente o que é justo do
que o direito dos advogados viram se uma
situação algo embaraçoso porque se
encontraram numa garagem de um hotel
o motel baixa fama de causando às vezes
prática é infidelidade conjugal
só que encontrar no seu seio do carro
deram frente um com o outro mas com uma
particularidade é que dão de homs estava
com a mulher do outro a se passar um
pouco estranha e ficaram algo
triplicados e propõe preços este ano
também é e tentaram resolver o problema
o falando assim o carinho advogados a
diversos segmentos falar às vezes um
pouco estranha temos nossos legal então
o primeiro que teve mais poder de reação
diz bom em primeiro lugar
apresento os meus cumprimentos ao menos
35 é gum vem com mais dinheiro os
presentes e devo dizer que situação
essas constrangedora
como eu gosto de conhecer a e como
efetivamente o próprio ambiente
fisionomia dos presentes bem nota
todavia como estão dizendo goiás e pará
nós somos pessoas do direito eo direito
comanda é que cada um de nós olha para
sua cidade desenvolvida para casa
repondo enfim os ditames do código civil
o colega isso vai ter lugar também é
presente mas complementar 105 ainda vai
mais ser os presentes e é possível como
sempre retórica afiada contundente em um
símbolo mas não desempenha com quem é
muito difícil circular só que no caso
vertente diria que não estou totalmente
de acordo porque se revela que é de
direito
que eu era ministro antes de voltar pra
casa é assim procedendo depois de cinco
anos
não direi que é uma seleção que não é
justa
por enquanto os restantes cinco que já
está a sair e eu estou apenas a chegar
olha ai essa história
simboliza um pouco a diferença pode
haver entre o direito positivo ea
justiça e ao longo dos anos o direito
positivo tento é fez suar sérgio diz nem
sempre conseguiu como diz os países de
tutoriais também têm direito mulheres
grandes juristas como o carlos mito no
tempo do ginásio que é um grande
professor de direito um brilhante
professor jaime e que foi muitas vezes
criticado pelo suavizam as que eram 11
próprio sustentáculo surgindo de
tutorial e por isso temos de ter este
daí o direito ea justiça não são a mesma
coisa
bom nós temos progredido um pouco mais
para ver se conseguimos perceber com que
justiça é que temos ser justo é e com
toda a sinceridade a dar uma idéia de
que para as pessoas que não estão muito
dentro do nosso maio a apreensão da
justiça é feita de uma ou duas maneiras
ou através de casos concretos que tenham
vivido na sua própria existência
um problema laboral que teve terminar no
tribunal um problema do momento direita
família um problema no âmbito do
condomínio ou qualquer outro então
membro em um pouco o sistema judicial
por e pela forma como tratou o seu
próprio problema ou então através da
comunicação social porque ao contrário
do que acontecia a vinda 30 40 anos hoje
hoje as matérias de justiça disputam o
protagonismo é qualquer outra matéria
e mais as baterias justiça são
omnipresentes por variadíssimas razões
porque envolve pessoas muito conhecidas
ou porque envolvem pessoas que passam a
ser conhecidas e não eram conhecidas
regra geral os move um tipo e depois
porque se abre um debate público é sobre
a importância ea pertinência os atrasos
da justiça
mas mais do que isso muitos outros
usar resgato cidade e desemboca na
própria diz hoje por exemplo quer da
política quer no futebol as pessoas
estão adquirindo o senhor vai ter de
explicar a isso está a dizer no sítio
próprio aliança tribunais poderia
chamar-se com sede própria vai ter
provado em sede própria
a dúvida no sítio próprio nosso sítio
próprio já vamos ver como é que quando
uma enxurrada de matérias primas
tribunais e não era assim
é para que há dois movimentos muito
importantes com frio gente que afetam é
o funcionamento do sistema judicial
há muito mais direito a muito mais de
ver os já muito mais conhecimento dos
dirigentes dos diversos há uns anos a 30
40 50 anos é maya legislativa era
claramente inferior não se falava em
direitos ambientais
praticamente todos falava em crimes
fiscais não havia sequer há 50 anos
importante talvez houvesse e porque já
que 56 mas creio que não
a construção do condomínio não havia
mais em atividades rurais será desligado
igual vavá não discrimina são grandes
ligados à os concursos públicos quando
uma quebra quebra de subir cara compra
estou comprando aquilo tem que fazer
concurso público
a regra só aumentou de forma brutal não
sei se tem idéia de vossa própria vida
do conjunto do laser que estão adstritos
às do condomínio da vossa casa as leis
do código da estrada é joelho não puder
fumar aqui dentro o meu poder fazer
ruído a partir de uma certa hora em que
as relações que tem com o banco que
emprestou nery como tudo nery para o
empréstimo da casa e as relações
estabelecidas no âmbito da actividade
laboral lá vai poder prestar relações
com a as autoridades fiscais poderiam
estar e inúmeros exemplos
o mundo está cheio de regras e é normal
que o mundo cheio de regras caos
congestionamento nos tribunais porque os
tribunais viva e também uma um poema
dificuldade ea oferta ea procura e por
tantas questões não se resolvem só com
retórica embora a retórica seja uma
coisa
eu acho que os alunos retórica às vezes
dois um exemplo para se perceber como as
palavras têm alves um significado amigo
e co
o exemplo de um general meu conhecido
que um dia possa significar doutor jairo
aos gostava de conhecer a sua opinião
quanto aquilo que eu disse o motorista
se considera que é uma coisa odiosa ou
não e se então que cristo turistas geral
e os motoristas diz que dirigentes em
geral
um senhor é um homem extraordinário
evento diante elas suas mais de 200 que
o rio só que não se nota nada eo general
estava um pouco admirava e eu próprio
tive umas certas dificuldades em
explicar geral sim ou não eu poderia ser
menos rigoroso embora tenha dito que sim
porque apesar de tudo a primeira parte
foi mais condimenta lá ia atribuir à
pouca perspicaz um turista não notar
aqui o que quer para lutar antes mas que
é produzido por isso é que há uma velha
é o conhecimento e se diziam os
seminaristas segundo resolvem venda olha
tu vai consumir nário dura e portanto
tudo o que leva a perguntar aos padres
boxes fumar enquanto retas
têm de perguntar se pode usar enquanto
fuma e portanto por exemplo importância
das palavras ganha alguma arrogância e
nem sempre é muito claro o que elas
pretendem dizer mas é uma coisa que vos
queria transmitir e foi por aí consegui
o retalho é que há uma retórica solução
dos problemas que surgem quando usada no
ideário político parece resolver tudo em
todo lado pessoas perguntam qual é sua
política para a justiça de goiânia para
a justiça e simples aumentar a oferta
dos tribunais criar processos mais
correntes simplificadas leões diminuir a
dependência também mesmo é que espaço no
vasco no programa que é um ótimo
problema não sei se já leu
sabem atualmente ninguém os programas
ninguém não sei ler que continua
produzindo então a solo para ver se
descobrem alguma incongruência que é
igual a 10 anos ou igual a 15 anos e há
uma maneira de mudar os temas que
procurou ocultar por trás da retórica é
que o que é óbvio em que justiça tem
problema de oferta e procura
eu exijo respeito visível que a retórica
florença perdeu origem é momentos
engraçados conta sua história de um
advogado que estava a defender com
algumas dificuldades que o valor das
horas que eu entenda falaram que ele
estava a defender com algumas
dificuldades
um jovem acusado de matar princípio e
pague civil ou seja muito o papai e
mamãe eo juiz perguntava então estava
pendendo nada matar seus pais porque a
herança uma bomba no carro bomba que foi
bem a única coisa estou arrependido por
ter sido apanhado dos sentimentos o rio
é natural de penedo é é bom ser
desvendado agora tem a palavra prol de
ações que eu tenho a certeza de que o
tribunal se com isso deste pobre órfã
às vezes nós temos de recorrer a alguma
sabedoria e alguma gente quer mas porque
é que no final eu queria que não fosse
os justiça para nós temos um painel da
actividade judiciária muito vasto
nós temos justiça criminal talvez seja
mais conhecida porque é mais
publicitados nos órgãos públicos social
nós temos processo o nome engraçados a
rota do atlântico ou para sambar queijo
operação você que tá esses são mateus
que as pessoas aprendem mais da sua vida
que não é ligada a essa matéria
nós temos tribunais do trabalho onde se
dirigem às questões entre empregadores e
empregados ou outras de que na ação
dessa confusão temos tribunais fiscais
temos tribunais administrativos onde
dirimir as questões das pessoas ea
instrução os concursos hulk
as promoções na tv ligadas à a alguns
municípios nenhuma de estágio a
tribunais do lille com caso complicado
isso inclui dados das responsabilidades
parentais quando nomeadamente pai mas
denunciam é ver a minha coisas aos
tribunais civis por tribunais de
cobrança de dívidas a processos
executivos a um processo coletivo e
justamente porque a pessoa já estou
muito mais diante dos seus direitos e
muito mais cientes dos seus deveres
essa parte é regra dos outros o mais
simples dos vírus hiv há muito mais mas
muito mais notícias irá nós teremos em
tribunal e trazer aqui alguns do jornal
cristão e sujeitas é fácil porém a
direção geral das políticas difícil www
itau poderão ver nós temos mais dois
milhões de processos cíveis em portugal
em portugal nascem por ano cerca de 500
mil inquéritos criminais 500 mil
inquéritos criminais e continuamos com o
modo de fazer justiça que é um modo
ainda do século 20
portanto ninguém tá aí uma assunção
clara e que possa ser facilmente
compreensível pestana se ouvirem dizer
que alguém está a candidatar ao que quer
que seja tem uma função e quadra pra
resolver um problema que consiste
esta pergunta simples como é que os
novos tribunais vão resolver em tempo
muito considerado rápido considerada do
quadro é as pendências mixhell tem a
função e média é menos que se opte por
crimes de extermínio processual por
exemplo aumentando os custos do acesso o
tribunal que é o que tem feito
aumentando os custos ao tribunal
procurando dissuadir as pessoas de irem
para tribunal e diminuindo os recursos
eu sou advogado há 30 anos quando eu
comecei a exercer advocacia em 1987 era
muito mais fácil recorrer
havia muito mais recursos de tudo e mais
alguma coisa
recursos que suspenderam as decisões
tomadas hoje quase nenhum vasco e
continuamos ouvindo dizer que os
recursos que estão na base do problema
com que medida é verdade é outra e bem
diferente é que este problema com muitos
outro não tem mais função simples não
tem uma solução simples e por vezes
retórica da função política tenta
simular e transmitirei daí que tem como
função simples
aliás como sabem eu tenho aproximar do
fim
como sabem nós temos uma maneira de
falar que ela própria muito complicado
um político e presidente por exemplo de
estados unidos um país no qual saxony
fala normalmente se perguntarem alguma
coisa outro ponto sim mas quando não
talvez mês desta forma agora mais
espalhafatosos digamos assim que
caracteriza por exemplo 200 estados
unidos em portugal
nós temos um mundial muito enviesado
embora tenhamos feito alguns progressos
continuando sem ter um dia alguém no ato
por exemplo eu lembrei me disto pode
exaltar a pergunta óbvia
olha se eu não ganhar as eleições fica
vereador ou não um país não gostar só no
evento e sim não é portugal já estava à
espera de uma criança pergunta
e os portugueses saibam que não fuja por
conta de uma então fica no momento eu
voltar quando eu quiser
também estão lá agora talvez agora já
quer pronto
ora essa pergunta é uma pergunta que eu
treino pondera
num quadro de avaliação clara e
sustentava todo universo a transação
seja se não só não vou dizer que não
saia mas fica ou não fica
vamos citar a institutos poder deixa o
timoneiro da nau que o programa agora
está a acabar pronto então pronto então
ficamos sem saber e nós esta linguagem é
uma linguagem também contamina universo
judiciário são perguntou às vezes amigos
meus prontamente 8 o que faria se fosse
pra lá que faria bom primeira coisa que
é importante reconhecer o problema do
funcionamento da justiça considerar como
é hábito como estes tribunais vão jogar
naquelas pendências
os milhões de processos que têm ao seu
cuidado e começar a resolvê los de forma
marcelo é um problema difícil e que não
se resolve no curto prazo o sistema
coisa anticlímax por exemplo para um
político isso não se pode dizer
a segunda coisa é preciso simplificar
profundamente o nosso de altos de
judiciário
nós continuamos a ter sentenças centenas
páginas processo de grande complicação
intervenção o odor a unidade muito pouco
aproveitada coisas que são muito fáceis
de ser i limb algo e não em troca de
papéis não em troca do país cinco dias
para hunter dia para o outro pois outras
como e depois o juiz se depois o outro
record não nós temos fazer justiça à
secom 21 e justiça' século 21 é fazê lo
de uma forma muito muito muito mais
bonita cuidando que é sócio e mantendo
que é essencial e que é essencial de
constituição justiça e de defesa dos
direitos e defesa da igualdade de
direitos e igualdade do tratamento
o tempo é que vai pra não dizer afinal
queijo porque elas distinto direito em
que o nosso equipamento fizemos quando
fizemos assim isso não é justo eu estou
na fila
tudo que há uma hora vai mobilizou passa
na frente não é justo eu não concordo
que tendo ficado em primeiro lugar no
concurso passa a minha frente ao rei
porque me ea de óxi e ficou meu emprego
não é justo
nós temos uma noção do que justiça e é o
que a criação do direito que incorpora
em igualdade entre as pessoas
igualdade de oportunidades uma lei é
igual para todos foi uma das grandes
vitórias da construção gislativa foi
acabar com ele e me treinar como sabem
antes do status liberais de matriz
liberal em que lai guiné que os
anglo-saxónicos dos americanos chamam de
rua vó o rei por isso aconteceria com
forma substituição alguém fazer alguma
coisa aí o senhor já não matam provar
suas 50 anos página leva para a áfrica
boxes tendo sido já estava mal disposto
a cortar a cabeça era a falta de
controle do dólar e pelos comportamentos
públicos e privados
e essa lei também prevê metrô aumenta
tal igualdade não discriminação
tratamento subir nário do cidadão e para
que a justiça esteja no direito tem de
prover este revelado em prover tais
prerrogativas que estão nomeadamente da
declaração universal dos direitos do
homem
para terminar porque temos e just com a
justiça já agora nós estamos sempre
comparar o nosso sistema judicial com
outros temas disse que não assistiu os
estados unidos podem chamá-lo
uma foi lo preso isso temos também dizer
isso mesmo
como sabem os estados unidos de nori gem
ignora crise do sistema financeiro que
depois como um dominó varreu a europa ou
américa e na europa
quantas pessoas foram presas nos estados
unidos é preciso atenção isto quanto
tempo durou o processo de investigação
do mal a nós por vezes também não
conseguimos ver o que pesar tudo nosso
sistema judicial vai conseguir fazer
a introdução de tecnologias infelizmente
os sítios que é um ótimo sistema de
trabalho só foi possível quando não
gerou toda a agenda vazia então sei que
agora para o ocidente não se tem uma
coisa boa
a introdução apesar de tudo há alguma
diz formalização das lajes e acima de
tudo temos a noção que este problema que
isso leva da justiça em portugal é muito
semelhante ao vivo em espanha o que se
vê em frança ao silva e tal e auxílio na
bélgica é tem ao crivo dos estados
unidos que não é um problema próprio
negócio às vezes nós mesmos criamos o
nosso sistema como se eu fosse algo do
ridículo e patético nomeadamente quando
comparado com outros países europeus no
que não é roubado
não quer dizer que isso não sirva de
cônsul mas não é pra lá
agora mesmo para terminar a uma história
do ano se conhecido anderson que o
tanque ser muito por exemplo no meu
espírito que a história do douro vai vai
como sabe essa história é muito básica
mas por alguma razão por alguma razão
sobrevivo há cerca de 200 anos de
história tem apenas a ver com isto ou
sair queria arranjar um a vestimenta
melhor do que qualquer outra pessoa e
por ser um dois bolões prisão se deu bem
nós temos um investimento para
extraordinária mexe tem um problema com
o plano só pessoas muito inteligentes e
conseguem perceber como aquela foto j
extra-ordinária bom e os refúgios provas
e via ao espelho e não teria chance de
200 então achava muito a sua falta e
continuava com os novos pagamentos pelas
ruas
isolde que também eram 200 diziam não
falta é ótimo conjunto 11 mil disposição
vai nu
e nessa altura toda a inteligência
estimulou e souza chegaram confrontados
com o fax ngelo que o reino mas foi
preciso que uma criança que não tem essa
vontade sufismo de ser muito inteligente
diz s
mas usa aí vai nu e portanto eu não
quero dizer com isto que a justiça seja
sanada
aliás fiz aqui eu tenho em minha defesa
do sistema
agora o que preciso e antes entrar na
abordagem de resolução do problema e é
preciso ter coragem de reconhecer o
problema e não vontade sistemática de
mascarar o problema de procrastinar como
há pouco que o nosso blog nos dizia e eu
deixo desta mensagem informa es hoje há
muita informação que está na internet
façam o vosso próprio juízo sobre
justiça substitutos não não deixem que
sejam outras pessoas a pensarem por voz
obrigado
[Aplausos]